[Music]
with rising inflation and higher prices
on pretty much everything right you may
be relying on dividends from investment
accounts or other savings to get by and
financial advisors encourage starting
your nest egg as early in life as
possible and our sherry swens tells us
that younger women are getting into that
very and they're very wise doing that
if you waited until later in your career
to invest in retirement savings or even
playing the stock market chances are
you're going to spend the rest of your
working years playing catch-up recent
studies show younger women are much
savvier to early investing and steering
their own course for financial security
carla mcgonna and alicia lectworth are
students in unlv's lee business school
they're at different stages of life but
both want a career where the money they
make will be working for them i think
money makes the world move as a lot of
us know so a finance and accounting
major carla already knows that one key
to growing her money is not putting off
till tomorrow what she can invest today
the most valuable thing that i've
learned is to really start looking into
those investment opportunities early in
your career alicia is returning to
school from the workforce with a lot of
experience and a son in his twenties
she's going after her masters in
business and wants to be financially
independent you never know what's coming
at you in life even if you're young and
healthy you just don't know
you know you shouldn't depend on your
partner your parents or somebody else to
be managing your money for you and
understanding how it works cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger agrees
and says women should first learn to
bank on their own longevity women are
going to statistically live longer than
men so if you happen to be partnered
with a man who is of the same age then
you're probably going to outlive him a
nest egg that grows as your life
experience is due is important and it's
not that hard to get started it is so
much easier to invest now than for
anyone who is over the age of 35
investing is as easy as opening up an
app on a phone and plugging in
information a recent fidelity investment
study of 2000 investors shows most of
the women 35 and older waited to open an
investment account until at least the
age of 30 about 10 years later than
younger women surveyed about the same
was true for retirement savings in fact
about 50 percent of gen z and
millennials say they have started
investing in the past year or planned
too soon while 36 percent of older women
regret waiting too long to build their
security and just to prove how starting
younger can really pay off a 25 year old
putting away just 50 dollars a month can
make about a hundred thousand dollars
more than a woman who waits until the
age of forty with slightly more invested
over the long run i think there has been
a lot more education
and a lot more media attention on how
important it is to start early
in your investing life so starting early
and taking a little risk when you can
afford it could pay off great rewards
when you need it most if you start early
with small amounts and trial and error
and just try to learn a little bit as
you go along you'll amass really a lot
of knowledge very quickly and become
really more of an expert
and hopefully a lot of money and
hopefully a lot of money schlesinger
says another reason to start early is to
make up for pay inequality women may
still encounter in the workforce if
you're making eighty percent of what
your male counterpart is making it will
take longer and more money to save
enough for retirement the full interview
with cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger is on our website eight
newsnow dot com sheri swensk live local
now
gotta save save save do it now